on this episode I talk about speaking
fees am I an expert or near an expert
and while I left a daily wait
you
welcome to the Garry Boucher I am very
bad luck and my friend is my favorite
number
Kelsea asks what are your thoughts on
starting to share content before you're
an expert do you wait or do you share
your journey cousin it's an interesting
question I first of all I think this
whole expert thing is a ridiculous
notion am I an expert are you an expert
are you an expert you know I mean you
know when does one get to claim they're
an expert I mean I thought I was an
expert when I was 22 I'm pissed that I
wasn't able to make these videos when I
came out the gate in 98 and brought
serious Thunder to the wine world you
would have saw a young raw hungry angry
Gary Vee and that would have been really
interesting to look back on
so I say map that journey baby because
the truth is expert is subjective I've
seen people tweet that I'm a bigger
expert than people that I think are way
more accomplished than me and then other
people put me in tweets with other
people that I clown every day of the
week more more value in this pinky than
them so expert is clearly subjective and
more importantly here's the real
punchline put that content out because
you're going to be able to look back at
that content your grandkids are going to
be able to look back at that content
plus you will see things and how they
evolved my 1998 video would have been in
2002 every single person is going to go
into a store with a cell phone because
they're blowing up in London right now
and they're going to come in and be able
to tell the price of every single
product so sell your products that cost
and that would have been a big no wrong
that would have been fun to look at so
there are no experts except if the
audience gives you an expert if somebody
deems you an expert as young talent out
the gate then kudos on you start filming
now mark asks when you left the daily
grade was it for me show or for
vaynermedia mark I left it for
vaynermedia um Misha was already 2 years
old at that point this is August 11 that
I think I shut down daily great you know
it was five and a half years of everyday
doing a video show and it just ran its
course I mean the
lots of doing a video show every day
would like freak me out right now Andrew
asks how do you change the culture to
one of genuinely caring about the
customer when the current ethos is so
established Andrew Andrew
there's only one way to change the
culture when it's broken to something
genuine kill leadership leadership is in
charge of the culture everything my
friend stems from the top when it gets
into the DNA so do not let the leader
the CEO the board whoever it may be do
not let her him make an excuse that
something's happening below in middle
management or some other things because
she's in charge he's in charge of that
middle management every problem at
vaynermedia
is my fault right here you're looking
right at the space it's my fault cuz I
empower everybody else to create that
culture and so how do you change it you
change the top and at the top owns it
because it's the family business or just
became the new CEO and it's not going to
change and need to get the hell out of
there because the only people that can
change culture are the people from the
top it's true you can hack from the
bottom you can maybe then inspire the
top but that top still has to make the
decision that is the judge of culture
Sora asks how do you book speaking
engagements when you weren't well-known
yet so the way I book speaking
engagements when I wasn't well-known yet
was I did them for free the entitlement
that you are not known you did not
deserve to get paid do you know why you
get paid to speak because you put asses
in the seats because people want to come
and see you the reason I get
astronomical speaking fees is knock on
wood zoom in here let me knock on wood
Macca wood I'm very fortunate to have an
audience that want to travel and go to
these events and that's why you get
justified those fees you don't get paid
if you're not bringing any value so
either your content is phenomenal but
even then if you're not putting asses in
the seat you are not getting paid so the
best way to do it is to do what I did in
my opinion which is I spoke for free in
the beginning quite a bit to establish
my name to show everybody how good I was
at it and then the man side came to it
David asks since you publish a crush
what big changes have you seen an online
content creation and how can people
maximize them David what's up brother
hope you doing well enjoy our filming
years ago glad to get you on the show um
biggest thing that's changed really is
you know everything's just become so
much bigger since 2009 Facebook is such
a bigger powerhouse than it was back
then new things like snapchat and vine
and all these things so it's really
everything I saw coming at least in that
way has come true these things have
grabbed more attention YouTube and vine
celebrities are bigger than real
celebrities to the 13 to 18 year old
demo that's going to continue and go
full scale and so the opportunities are
to find the medium you're best at some
people rockbind some people rock
snapchat if you're going to taking
pictures and drawing on top of yourself
snapchat might be your place if you
might be great at Pinterest to the
female demo making infographics
beautiful pictures Instagram we've seen
a whole mergence of stars curators
people have talent and so just more new
avenues are coming out and so I'm just
more the same more the same tactics
crush it's tactical advice to the
platform might be outdated but the
thesis has never run more true thanks
everybody for watching episode 5 fever
as they call it in the streets I
appreciate it
please subscribe up we talked about this
d-roc don't don't screw up I want a lot
of you but I hope this is it that just
happen get better be there do it I am
very thankful for this show we got the
five episodes a big accomplishment go
look into the details
80% of shows online don't make it to
Episode five so we're in the 20% son
when you with a little bit me we are
changing the Q&A rules whether they like
it or not
everybody this is the askgaryvee show on
this episode I'm gonna talk about movies
impact on my career my health and
how it